hey youtubers is Charlie and arrow in
the flash just released this this
picture here
teasing their big crossover so I wanted
to dedicate a video just explaining how
that's gonna work as well as give a big
update on all the shows that DC Comics
has in development there's a lot of them
like Supergirl for instance hello it's
any new people if you're just finding me
for the first time I'm gonna be doing
arrow and flash videos all season long
so be sure to subscribe to join the team
I'm also doing all the other comic book
shows big heads up - they just delayed
the arrow season to Netflix released
because of the DVD they just want the
DVD to earn more money that people that
make arrow like Stephen Amell Marc
Guggenheim the showrunner they have
absolutely no say in things like that if
they could find a way to give it to us
faster if they would totally do it with
that in mind I might dedicate one of my
future arrow bonus videos to just doing
a big season to recap if you guys feel
like it's necessary let me know if
people haven't seen it if they want me
to do a video like that just let me know
in the comments now for some sweet
crossover music this picture is
basically from the table read-through
meaning they all sit around giant tables
reading the lines in the script just to
explain who's in this picture and what's
going on first off if you look closely
you can see Stephen Amell there in the
middle he's wearing his arrow costume
leather pants they just call him the
arrow pants which is totally hilarious
they totally do not look comfortable to
just walk around and sit down in so then
from left to right there's Glen winter
the director of the two episodes is a
two-parter danielle panabaker
who plays Caitlin snow may or may not
have powers on the flash her alter ego
in the comics is killer frost then
there's David Ramsey who we all know and
love is Diggle
Jesse Martin who's playing detective
West Candice Patton who's playing iris
West
and has her arm wrapped around Emily
BETT who we all know and love is
Felicity then there's Rick cos net play
is Eddie Thawne keep your eyes peeled on
him then we have our quarterback Stephen
Amell here in the middle in tight pants
Grant Gustin then Patrick Savin Oogie
who plays the captain of the Central
City Police Department where Barry works
then there's Marc Guggenheim who's the
showrunner on arrow and Tom Cavanagh
who's playing Harrison wells the person
who runs STAR Labs the actual crossover
is gonna look a little bit different for
what your might used to just because the
CW owns both shows and has all the
actors under contract
in addition CW's owned by Warner
Brothers which also owns DC Comics so
they have the rights to all the
characters it just means it's a little
bit easier for them to play in this
universe than it is for other networks
on top of that they grew the flash show
out of arrow both in terms of characters
and in terms of production staff so like
the people that are writing and
producing the flash also used to write
and produce on arrow they're like a big
family so it's much easier for them to
communicate which is very rare in
television structurally this crossover
is just gonna be a two-hour story broken
into two one-hour parts each of those
one-hour parts is gonna take place on
each different show they haven't said
which show is gonna get the first part
but the flash airs first during the week
so if they want to complete the
crossover in a single week they'll
probably just do part one on the flash
and then the next day do part two on
arrow that's at least what I'm hoping
happens because who wants to wait a
whole week to find out what happens in
part two we don't really know what the
story device is gonna be that's gonna
merit this big crossover like white team
arrow has to go on the flash and white
team flash has to come on the arrow it's
possible they could pick some big event
out of the comics or it could be just
something totally new they come up with
they did specifically say that the flash
show is sticking really close to the
flash rebirth comics but arrow plays a
little fast and loose with cannon what
you can plan on is one or two characters
from each show just going on the other
they're not gonna have every single
member of each team on screen at the
same time logistically it would just be
a nightmare because last year's
mid-season finale on arrow turned Barry
Allen into the flash I'd been on
something major happening like the
reveal of the reverse flash or zoom or
however they wanted to find the big bad
on that show I'll talk more about him in
a separate flash video but of all the
big reveals they could make there's the
reverse flash Brandon Roth's Ray Palmer
could join Team arrow full-on he could
get his atom super suit the Rogues could
come together as a team for the first
time and we can see Ra's al Ghul for the
first time I'm just gonna say Russell I
know raesha cool some of you want me to
say it that way but I've seen it both
ways on TV so I'm just gonna say Ross
for now they didn't cast Ra's al Ghul
til after the first couple of episodes
had already been shot so we might not
see him till that mean season finale or
even later last year on arrow that's
kind of around the time they made the
big reveal of Slade being the big bad so
it is possible
that they could reveal professor zoom as
well as Ra's al Ghul which actually
reminds me they just cast Captain
Boomerang on arrow because he used to be
part of the Suicide Squad in the comics
that's probably the kind of story
they'll introduce him in he was also a
member of the Rogues in the flash comics
so it's totally possible that Captain
Boomerang could be part of the big
crossover the really funny part about it
is that the actor they cast Nick Terra
Bay also used to be on Spartacus with
Manu Bennett so just think of the meta
thing going on with Deathstroke and a
lot of you been asking but Manu Bennett
has not been confirmed for arrow season
3 so I'm not expecting to see Slade
moving along some other big happenings
Brendan Roth was teasing his Ray Palmer
atom suit like I said it could totally
be revealed in that mid-season finale
but in the interview that he just did he
explained that they had just shot about
six episodes the interview is old so
obviously now they're getting ready to
shoot the mid-season finale which is
episode 9 but he said that he had just
seen concept art of his atom suit
meaning they hadn't made it yet I would
plan on it looking like something close
to this but without the super bright
colors like they'll just tone it down
like Roy's red arrow costume it's just
like a toned down version of red it's
not like bright red
it does take them a while to make those
costumes so it's possible that we won't
see it to like right before the actual
finale next year in terms of character
arts Brandon rouse said most of his
scenes in those first six episodes are
just with felicity meaning we'll see a
lot of Felicity and Ray Palmer doing
things without Oliver around I feel like
people are gonna love Ray Palmer but
hate Ray Palmer and Felicity together
maybe not everyone but he's gonna be a
romantic foil for Oliver Brandon Rawe
said it's basically his job to come
between him and Felicity Oliver is the
real protagonist of the series we're
supposed to root for him so whenever
someone comes between him and felicity
obviously we're supposed to not like it
speaking of felicity Marc Guggenheim the
showrunner has been teasing some
Felicity related behind-the-scenes stuff
first he posted this picture it's the
inside of Felicity's apartment tumblr
went absolutely crazy whenever he posted
this just look at the Robin Hood poster
above her TV it seems totally
appropriate and then just as I was
making this video like literally in the
last hour he also posted this image it's
a sign from Sherwood florist in the
comics the longbow hunters story Oliver
Queen and black Canary moved to Seattle
when they moved there Black Canary gets
a
flower shop and names it Sherwood
florist the two of them end up living in
the apartment above the shop but they
use the building as their base of
operations so Eric could turn Sherwood
florist into the new verdant for the
arrow cave
just because verdant was basically
destroyed or it could totally just be
wherever Felicity's new apartment is in
the trailer we saw her working it like a
Nerd Herd type job so I don't think that
she owns the flower shop like in the
comics so here a couple important dates
you guys need to remember October 7th
the flash premieres that's three weeks
and then the next day arrow premieres
they're both on the CW obviously the
same Channel but they both premiere at
8:00 p.m. on each night also happening
on the 7th Netflix is dropping arrow
season 2 at least in the United States
for all you people in international
countries just check your local listings
sometimes you have to wait a week to get
new episodes of arrow but whichever
channel that arrow aired on last year is
the same channel that the flash will be
on this year they'll be on the same
Channel so moving along here's the
details on all the big new comic book
shows that DC has in development at
various networks first up there is a new
super dark animated version of Justice
League from Bruce Timm if you're not
familiar with him he's basically the guy
behind like all the best
DC Comics animated shows like Batman the
Animated Series Batman mask of the
phantasm Batman Beyond and the Justice
League cartoon from about 10 years ago
when they say darker version I just
think of it being more like Batman the
Animated Series in terms of tone no word
on when we're gonna get to see it it
takes up to 6 months to animate a single
episode of television so it might be
like 2016 before we see anything then
there's the live-action Teen Titans
they're just calling it Titans at TNT I
already did a big video about this so
I'll just add a link in the description
but it's still in the pilot stage then
there's Supergirl from Greg Berlanti in
a co-writer role and he's also the guy
behind arrow in the flash and he said a
whole bunch of other non comic book
shows he's super successful so I'm very
optimistic this is gonna happen they are
still getting ready to shop it 2
networks but it's not gonna be on the CW
and it won't be called Supergirl if
everything totally works out I plan on
seeing this fall 2016 maybe 2017 just
depending on whenever they shoot the
pilot next is our man that's being
developed at CW Geoff Johns announced it
last year but it's been about 10 months
we've heard anything so it's possible
that the project is dead since the CW
isn't gonna be doing that Super Girl
show it's possible that they could just
take this our man project to another
network then Fox networks just picked up
a show called Lucifer the character
Lucifer Morningstar originated in Neil
Gaiman's Sandman comic eventually got
his own spin-off comic and Fox just
bought the rights so we probably not
gonna see this until 2017 next up is
preacher based on the Garth Ennis comic
Seth Rogen and Adam Goldberg these two
guys are developing it for AMC a
showrunner and two executive producers
have been hired so it seems like this is
moving along nicely but I would not plan
on seeing any news about it till next
year maybe 2016 premiere date next up is
scalped based on the vertigo comic
that's in development at the WGN network
it's being described as like a Sopranos
on a Native American reservation there
isn't a showrunner yet so they're
probably still working on a script for
the pilot then there's DMZ that's
another vertigo comic it's in
development at Sci Fi
it takes place in like this post-civil
war in New York of the future which has
been turned into a demilitarized zone
thus the dmz title but this is actually
pretty interesting sci-fi is also
turning the Frank Miller Ronin comic
into a miniseries just a miniseries not
like a full show it's about a ronin
samurai who failed to protect his master
from a demon he wakes up in the body of
a new person 800 years later and has to
fight the same demon for control of a
magical sword so that's a ton of new
comic book shows but this is like the
time of the year whenever networks
announce which news shows they just
bought they're really only a couple
times a year that happens so if there
are new comic book shows that start
happening we probably won't hear about
it till next year here's the big
question though of all the new shows I
just listed which are you most excited
to see I'll definitely say I'm pumped up
about a new Bruce Timm animated Justice
League so the next video I'm working on
is gonna be a history video for
Constantine I'm gonna be explaining his
history in the comics and how it's gonna
work on the show so be sure to subscribe
to get that I've also seen the first
episode so I might post a review of that
next week like a non-spoilery review but
right now you can click here to get that
I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post it
you can click here to get my
non-spoilery review of the Gotham's
premier thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you